the most expensive I have should be or
weed you know a fight plus the autograph
a thing is more than 3,000 us Nike
release them in 99 so it's already like
24 years ago I 500 pair of shoes
I think that's 1 million today ok but
don't tell my wife
so we put some silica gel inside and
then we're father this paper is useful
actually
and then you have to be called vacuum
that way we will keep the shoes looks
like the new one around more than 10
years but after parties actually you
cannot look in a letter for all possible
guys they will fit nike air George is
not a choice it's not only a parachute
for us especially some mainland China
people they starts maybe they're tired
with collecting wet wine think of
collecting washes so they start to
soothe so they really buy up all the
prices people willing to - for a week
and without going washroom or maybe take
take part like two partners come and go
you know is pain
right now because because sometimes it's
four times five times retirements people
are still willing to buy because of the
market Nike started 2% shoes with a
story behind and and people can actually
connect with the story
so they've won that you were I don't
think in the near future lies five years
ten years are adequate this is happened